foreign
[Music]
welcome I really appreciate you taking
the time to um to listen to this
discussion and
I'm very very excited to to talk to you
about uh communication of that and
crisis world and this presentation is
really going to focus on on risk
communication and and how can we as
scientists uh think about uh how can we
efficiently communicate with people who
are not scientists maybe part of a
general public uh or lay audiences if
you will and the big question is of
course like why why am I talking to you
this and and uh and and how do we get
there and how is this relevant then just
let me let me very quickly share a
little bit of myself uh my name is imeb
audio and
um my background is in medical science
so I'm for 10 years
um I was I was in I was in Labs I I
basically spent every single day of my
um of those 10 years in in a lab now I
did the experiments killed a lot of mice
as one with my research area was
actually the cardiovascular medicine but
after a time what really really got me
interested is okay this is awesome it's
awesome to generate science and it's
awesome to generate scientific
information and data but what really got
me going is how do we communicate that
and how do we make a great story out of
that data and how can we present it in a
meaningful way so that people can
understand that who are not scientists
and there are many ways that we do that
at the University Research Center I used
to teach
students medical students for uh for
over 10 years
um and it was that Joy uh that I felt
while was teaching that I really felt
like I really need to go deeper and
explore this idea of communicating
science to multiple audiences so I
really turned into this field of science
communication and within that because of
my expertise in in cardiovascular
medicine I turned more specifically to
health communication
um so after my Fulbright scholarship at
Harvard I transitioned to um master of
Public Health program at Columbia
University and I I obtained a degree in
health communication and I got a
certificate and certified as a health
education specialist in the US which uh
which is really me uh getting into this
whole new field of uh of communication
and and and my expertise really lies at
that intersection of Science and
communication right now
um this pathway led me to
uh Health Communications agency and
Manhattan so I worked for easy yellow as
a VP director of Behavioral learning
strategy and at the same time I'm also
senior lecturer at summerwise University
which is a medical school back in
Hungary I'm super excited
um to bring some thoughts to you around
how to expand into the non-scientific
World using our data and using the
science but making it really actionable
and applicable to large audiences so as
a part of that we're going to be
focusing on scientifically based risk
and how we communicate that risk to
large audiences
um
so this is where where we start the
conversation and this intro is really
meant to show why it is important for
scientists to be able to communicate
with the public and to communicate with
the public efficiently and one of the
reasons is that the threats that we as
Humanity face together like it or not
really really require cooperation on a
societal level but that cooperation
cannot be effective without a very
strong scientific grounding so to say
and that's when your work comes in you
have the science you're closest to the
scientific findings you're closest to
how research is done how research is
done well and how facts and data are
generated but in order the whole society
to act on these facts we need a
cooperation and we need to make that
happen and it has to start with your
work and your work has to expand into uh
into more of a societal context so what
you see here in the middle is with just
we're just experiencing the first wave
of these three waves that this graph
depicts like we're we're on some side of
the covid-19 pandemic right some argue
that we're over the worst part of it
some argue that the verses just just to
come
um we're still living with it and we've
seen in the last two to three years uh
how public-facing communication about
the science of code 19 uh has had some
pitfalls that had some had some
challenges and um and all sorts of ups
and downs to think that really
demonstrated
um the importance of of science
Communication in general and the bad
news is that no matter whether we think
covid-19 has ended or at there are other
threats ahead of us that need more
societal cooperation and so what are we
talking about climate change uh or
whether we're talking about the next
pandemic uh where they were talking
about monkey pox what are we talking
about anything else that may come up
come in our way it without being
specific
we need to think about how we
communicate clearly with uh with the
public and with patients and with and
with people who are not who might not be
experts
the next thing that that is really just
just gives us a high level context for
this is of course there's lots of
scientific knowledge out there and you
are where your work is part of
generating that huge amount of
scientific uh progress and scientific
data but there is a huge gap between
what scientists have gathered and what
the public actually understands and this
Gap needs to be filled in order for that
that big Society of cooperation
um to to work well and this Gap cannot
be filled with with just one approach
this Gap has to be filled from has to be
it has to be kind of uh filled with a
bridge that is being built from both
sides and from the public side there's
no question that we need better
education we need better Science
Education uh and we need better
information for the people to be able to
act upon them to be able to increase
their scientific skills it's not that we
want everyone to become a scientist but
we really really need to increase
people's scientific uh literacy on the
other side uh we scientists need to
become a little bit better in terms of
what we're in terms of what we're
communicating and how we're
communicating our findings
and then the last piece of this uh that
complicates the picture today is of
course the rise of misinformation and
many of you will have heard that
misinformation is nothing new to
humanity it has always been around uh in
certain shapes and forms but nowadays
because of the rise of social media and
it's a tremendous amount of social media
platforms that can uh that can spread
information very very in a very rapid
fashion we need to deal with this and
this is something that will interfere
with our messaging as scientists so
we'll talk about all these factors but
let's let's begin with some very very
very basic
um Concepts because why are we even
thinking about communicating risk and
what does this really mean to
communicate risk in an efficient way in
order to understand that we have a
couple of Behavioral Science Frameworks
which uh which I I would like to go
through very very quickly in a very very
high level fashion
so understanding the risk is key to
action we know from Behavioral Science
Frameworks that if people don't
understand the real threat they're being
faced with they're not going to act on
set threat and that seems very very
simple but there's a lot that goes into
that and if you take a look at this
graph which really shows what we call
the health belief model which is a very
one of one of the simplest behavioral
models that deal with more specifically
how people take action on health
Associated risks such as pandemics such
as a threat of an infection there are
two sides of the story there's one side
where people will think about what is
the risk what is really the risk that
I'm facing and the rudimentary that most
rudimentary understanding of that risk
has two components one centers around
severity
let's say we're talking about an
infection if I get this infection how
severe is it going to be
how bad is it going to be for me to get
it is it deadly is it lethal am I going
to get in a hospital if so how bad is it
going to be or am I just gonna am I just
gonna sit in my home for three days and
drink tea those are very very different
levels of severity the second component
of that you'll see in the left is
susceptibility very important question
am I susceptible to this disease can I
get it am I am I one of those people so
to say in plain language 2 will likely
get this disease or am I more protected
from this right
so it's it's a it's a very interesting
question and can lead to to much
misunderstanding so this is something
that needs to be very much clarified in
our in our messaging but so these two
components together form this idea of a
perceived risk on the other hand there's
um there's the perceived net value of
action as people are looking into
Solutions and people are thinking about
their behavior and there's a solution
offered in order in order for them to
take and act up on let's say it can be a
medication it can be vaccination to
prevent an infection they will think
about the value of that action first
what is the benefit of that action to me
and they will also think about the costs
and when we think about costs there can
be many things not just monetary right
what are some cognitive barriers in the
way uh am I afraid of needles
um is that something that will that will
eventually factor into the equation
um in a way that will impede my action
so there's two sides of this story again
assessing the risk the right way and
then assessing the behavior that is
presented to me to defend me from the
risk now the other behavioral model that
takes this one step further and and then
we'll we'll stop getting into into
Behavioral Science I promise but uh but
this this paints a little bit more
nuanced picture uh in terms of how this
risk assessment could work during a
state of emergency during uh during a
situation of emergencies such as
pandemic outbreak
so what people are faced with
um in these situations is there's
there's a health message coming in that
Health message is usually I mean coming
through a public health professional or
public health authority of course bad
message already originated in some sort
of scientific platform in a lab someone
has found something someone has
identified something that that
accumulated the public health
authorities took it over and now they're
communicating to the public and that
message usually contains here's the
threat and here's um and here's what you
need to do about that threat and this
model which is called the extended
parallel processing model actually talks
about two steps of assessing the
situation and it says that if either of
these steps people feel like they're um
they're they're not gonna take or
they're not going to want to take then
the whole process stops so step one
they're going to be assessing the threat
right very similarly to what we talked
about in the previous
um in the previous slide they're going
to be thinking about am I susceptible
and is this and is this severe enough is
the disease severe enough today so that
I should deal with it if the answer is
no they're not going to move forward in
the thought process no matter how well
we craft our messaging around why
vaccinations are important why you
should take this medication why this is
a really good form of prevention if
people feel like the risk is not worth
dealing with they're gonna stop right
away and this process is not going to
move forward to the to the next phase of
this risk assessment
in this in this model which is the
extended parallel process model The Next
Step once people feel like yes this is a
risk that I understand and then I need
to think about and it's serious enough
that I think about it the next message
processing around basically is around
what is the efficacy of the solution
that I'm presented right and when it
comes to efficacy there are two parts of
this what's the response efficacy if
you're presenting me with a vaccine how
efficacious is That vaccine right that
was a question that's a question that
we've been hearing for for over over two
years now it's a very important aspect
of of assessing uh assessing the
solution presented and the second part
of this conversation is what is my
efficacy what is that what does that
mean to be to for me to have an efficacy
it means that you know in order for me
to carry out the behavior I need to be
self-efficacious is this something that
I can do myself am I able to get that
medication get that get access to that
um that injection and my am I able to do
it am I able to carry out this this
behavior that is being presented to me
as the solution if the answer is no to
any of those any of those questions and
according to this model people are not
going to move forward and the message
processing they will just deny the
existence of this message and they will
not act upon the message
so these are a couple of things to think
about when we're communicating any sort
of risk and and any sort of scientific
data and perhaps solutions to what what
the data implies
now
diving a little bit deeper into into
people's understanding of risk how good
do we think people are really at
understanding uh science at all in
general so let's go back there and well
the answer is generally people are not
very good
uh if we take a look at the U.S we have
some survey data
that show us that about around 70
percent of the US can't read and
understand the science of New York Times
uh the science section of New York Times
which is not the deepest level of
science uh but um but just think about
that for a second I mean two-thirds of
the population is not going to be fully
able to understand what that science
section means that tells us a little bit
about generally
um what what the problem that we're
facing
now one-third of the population is
considered uh scientifically illiterate
right so that that means they're even
they have even lower levels of
scientific understanding now how they
measured like there's ways to measure
this and of course there's
questionnaires and and that this cannot
be perfect because there's so much
there's so many different forms of
science out there right so how can you
really measure what a person's
scientific literacy is this is a valid
questions but nevertheless uh there are
there are multiple surveys that show
that
these these percentages seem to be seem
to be correct so this doesn't put us in
a really really good position when we
need to communicate about scientific
data
and actually what uh what what the data
shows and what if you if you just take a
look around on the internet uh where
you'll see that most of the data
presented to people who are looking for
scientific information is actually way
above their average understanding so
this is this is a study that was uh that
was specifically looking into kobit 19
related website content and very simply
what the authors did in 2020 March this
took a couple of search words kobit 19
sarskov and so on and so on look at the
first 30 uh pages that Google served up
because they figure that people won't
even be looking uh after the first uh 30
30 fines or hits on Google and they just
looked at the reading level of these
websites and you'll see on the right
here that there is a pink line which
shows the average reading level of the
U.S population which is which might be
shocking but it's around the seventh
grade reading level right
um and of course this this differs for
certain populations and it differs with
the socioeconomic status with education
status but if you want to take a look at
the average it's around the seventh
level seventh grade level
everything that they found for covid was
above this right most of the hospital
materials and most of the even the
governmental
um Healthcare uh websites were higher
reading level around 12th 15th and so on
and so on so there's quite a bit of a
bit of a gap that people are facing when
they're looking for science information
so they have they have generally not so
great science literacy they're faced
with materials that generally too high
for them to uh to to comprehend or too
high level for them to comprehend
what happens what happens then if we
actually start increasing people's
scientific literacy level so let's let's
play around for this thought for a
second let's say that we educate people
and people get educated in scientific
facts their science literacy level
starts increasing
well this team's prediction was that if
there's if someone's science science
literacy level increases if there's a if
if there's like a ranking where where we
say you know on one axis of the curve
there's science literacy the ability to
understand science and on the y-axis
there's
um there's the perceived risk of of
climate change as a threat right which
is a which is a consensus fact in the in
the climate change Science World
the this group was predicting that with
increased science the literacy the
perceived threat the perceived risk uh
that that that the people will feel that
the climate change presents will
increase because they will understand
the science better and they will
understand how much of a threat it
really presents
now in terms of what they found in the
face of this hypothesis was the opposite
um let's just pause there because it's
shocking but it's um it's actually not
totally unexplainable right uh what this
tells us is that just because someone
has a higher level of science literacy
someone's more educated someone has more
background
um in terms of science in general
doesn't necessarily mean that they are
their perceptions of a certain risk is
gonna align with the perceptions of the
scientists right because there are many
many other factors that play into
um into the equation when people are
assessing risk their scientific
understanding is just one component of
that and there's a myriad of other
factors that play into actually viewing
and actually assessing scientific risk
belonging to certain groups better that
that could be political that could be
non-political groups and and and just
and just generally other emotional
factors that are associated economical
factors that go into that decision and
go into that risk appraisal process so
the results are pretty daunting but what
this really tells us is there's
something there's something Beyond just
the scientific understanding of a
certain risk that we need to take into
consideration when we're communicating
with uh with people and the next slide
really shows you this expanded
understanding of what we call risk
because I think as scientists when we
start thinking about risk a lot of times
what we what we start envisioning is
this measurable
risk magnitude times probability kind of
equation where we measure how really in
plane Works how bad is the risk and what
is the probability of a certain person
getting at risk we multiply that and we
have a concrete number that really tells
us the actual risk of of a certain uh
occurrence and this could be a risk of
catching catching a disease this uh this
could this could be a risk of
hospitalization if one gets gets
impacted with uh with a certain uh
infectious agent so
um what really the previous findings uh
tell us is that there has to be
something else out there in people's
minds that goes on and then modifies
this equation
so actually Peter Sandman who's uh who's
one of the lead believing risk
communicators
um that in the U.S formulated this uh
this formula which really talks about
two components of the risk assessment
one is about what it calls Hazard which
is our typical understanding of what a
measurable scientifically measurable
risk is but then there's a second part
of risk perception which we call outrage
and this outrage is the people component
of of the risk this is actually the
Public's reaction and people's own
reaction to what that risk is and if you
look at this this is an absolutely
mathematically incomplete and
mathematically uh might seem incorrect
what this really tells you is that
Hazard itself and just a scientific
understanding of risk is not taking you
far if you want to think about how
people perceive risk
actually if you take a look at
um at different you know a different
factors different occurrences different
different environmental threats
um that surround us and ask scientists
to
um to to put them in order in terms of
what they're worried about the most
versus versus the least and they rank
order these threats and you ask the same
from the general public and a good
sample of uh of of people
the correlation between those two
rankings will be very very very very low
it will be around 0.2 so this really
tells us that public is generally
worried about different things that
scientists are worried about so uh is
this surprising probably not so much
because there's a lot that is going on
into this outrage component here and
this is really without uh without trying
to be complete here and without trying
to paint a complete picture there are a
couple of things that a couple of
characteristics of a certain risk that
will determine how big the actual
outrage will be even if the scientific
risk so to say the measurable risk is
very low there are certain factors that
will influence there is perception of of
people and a couple of things on the um
on the left versus right if you look at
this coerced versus voluntary risk
coerced risks will always feel more
painful people will always be more
outraged by coerced risks than voluntary
risks what's a coerced risk right like a
very very recent example
is um as and we can talk about the risk
asset the risk perception here is valid
or not but a very very recent example is
um you know when when certain employers
requested uh vaccination for the
employees right now even though uh we
understand that vaccines are generally
generally super safe
um in the kobit 19 space and other
spaces you know people who think about
that threat uh you know as as non-zero
and now they're coerced so to say in a
way to take that risk versus General
Public who you know who are offered the
vaccine but they were never forced to
take the vaccine now these those people
who are react to the risk in a very very
different manner right so the core's
nature of the risk is important the
second here which is also a good example
and we can tie it back to covid-19 is is
the risk industrial or is there is a
natural risk people will always be more
outraged by an oil well let's say an oil
spill and the river which is which can
be traced back to a specific Factory so
to say versus a natural risk that occurs
um you know outside of our control and
outside of a company's control
so how does this relate back to covid-19
they remember the discussion at the
beginning of the pandemic whether this
came from a lab where covid-19 came from
a lab or it originated uh somehow in
nature like that that perception really
really modifies how outraged people are
and how they perceive the risk
then there are a couple of other factors
here I'm familiar versus familiar risk
obviously risks that are more exotic
that that people have not encountered
before
they uh they they there there's a higher
likelihood that outrage will uh will
occur in that situation is there is the
dreaded or not dreaded it's a very
interesting phrasing again comes from
Peter sandman's work but uh if we think
about ebola for instance where the
symptoms are really really terrifying
and and and and people have internal
bleedings and they die within uh within
a day
um and and so that picture that picture
is just uh it's just much more
terrifying for for a lot of people than
for instance catching a cold right so uh
even if the risk of catching something
might be very similar in terms of like
likelihood if the risk itself is more
dreaded uh that will cause more outrage
and then what is really interesting here
um is the catastrophic versus The
Chronic nature of risks uh which is
which is something that that I think we
all feel people are generally
um are generally more afraid of
catastrophe and afraid of things that
have low likelihood but they're more
catastrophic and they're more dramatic
when they happen think about a plane
crashing plane crashing has much much
much much
um less of a probability than a train
crashing or than a car crashing right
car crashes happen every day car crashes
have an everything every single day
every single month throughout the year
plane crashes uh do not happen
throughout the year they happen and it's
very very very well specified points in
time and then and then people really
focus on that and really feel like it is
a catastrophe because it is a
catastrophe it's just if you calculate
the number and you calculate the actual
risk that you're exposed to with a plane
ride it's still going to be much lower
than than what you're exposed to um
during a during a car ride
so these are factors to take into
consideration as we're as we're thinking
about how to talk how we talk about risk
and there are a couple of other
um thoughts here and a couple of on uh
other mental models that can help us
understand how people uh perceive risks
and how they present process risks one
is around negative dominance we know
that when people are upset they could
create their value on losses not
surprising people will be focusing on
the negative aspects
trust determination when people are
upset they commonly do not trust
Authority that does not put scientists
in a really really good position when
people are upset they will they will be
less likely to trust credibility and
classic Authority
mental noise
when people are in a stage of high
concern their ability to process
information is impaired now I think
we've all been there and we've all felt
that uh what's interesting here that the
same model poses that a new illness that
fits in it fits an infectious disease
prototype will be more easily understood
so if we come out during a pandemic and
we say this is going to be just like the
flu the and people will ease into that
very very quickly I know he said ah I
know that I think I know that I know the
risk it's familiar I'm I'm much more at
ease with that now I think one of the
biggest communication mistakes that
certain public health and authorities
and politicians made at the beginning is
making a lot of people believe that
kobit 19 is just like the flu
at because in certain aspects it's
similar yes but this mental model that
made people ease into this this mindset
okay maybe it's not that not too bad
because I I know the flu and it has
never killed me that caused a lot a lot
a lot lots and lots of damage at the
beginning of this uh this whole outbreak
so it was definitely a risk
communication mistake uh that could have
been identified
uh had we had I understood the risk
better
so we talked about a lot of problems
right uh we talked about people's low
level of scientific understanding uh we
talked about how even if people have
higher levels of scientific
understanding that doesn't really help
necessarily
um we talked about uh this issue of of
outrage and the myriads of factors that
go into that we talked about
misinformation so what really we as
scientists as as as
people are really doing it around what
can we do
um I'm not saying that this is just our
responsibility but are there some tools
that we can use and some Frameworks that
we can think about as we
um as we try to assess how to best
communicate uh the risk that
um that we're that we're finding so
there are three parts of this about the
presentation
um and we want to start with carefully
defining the actual Hazard that we're
talking about I'm gonna get there in a
second what we really mean it really
really makes a difference whether we
talk about a certain aspect of an
emergency situation or another aspect of
it so I'll bring an example in a second
the second part is really Thinking
Beyond the scientific meaning of risk
something that we already discussed like
just
one thing is the scientific
understanding of yours but there's a
whole other world
um outside of that and a whole other
host of factors that influence how
people perceive risk
and then the third component here is uh
how do we fight misinformation can we do
that oh like are there any tools
so
this is by no means a complete toolbox
but a couple of considerations that you
can take so let's start with defining
the risk well I would say and it's not
as easy as it sounds think about the
beginning of the code 19 pandemic the
beginning we were getting data from
China we were getting data from Northern
Italy in terms of what the fatality rate
of this disease was what the
hospitalization rate of this disease was
what certain what were the numbers we uh
we didn't really have reliable or
comparable measurements across countries
it was it wasn't amorphous monster this
whole package of data and it was
changing and evolving every single day
this is not this is not easy but
um emerging from that data there were
there was a very very clear Direction on
on behalf of Public Health authorities
and certain politicians for this push to
talk about fatality rates and it's
understandable people want to understand
if they're at risk of dying that's the
first thing I want to know about is am I
at risk of dying is my grandfather at
risk of dying is my loved one at risk of
dying so talk about fatality rates
absolutely like as a as a Baseline and
super important
um but uh what that did partially is
people looked at this number which again
was a moving Target one day it was one
percent the other way it was one point
five percent then it landed around 0.3
fatality so meaning that less than 100
people would die of this disease many
looked at this risk and might have said
that well that's not a huge risk right
and I'm healthy and I'm proud I probably
belong to the um to the less risky group
and so on and so on so this number did
not really help to raise the right
amount of awareness for this risk on the
other hand what was not really talked
about at the beginning was the extreme
rate of hospitalization at that point uh
in certain in certain States and in
certain parts of the world
hospitalization rates were between 1.1
and 10 which means that almost one out
of ten people who got covered at the
beginning phase without vaccines first
variant will get would get to a hospital
and again there was Regional variability
uh um in that but that is a fascinating
number that is absolutely not comparable
for instance to the flu right in the
case of a flu that's one in a thousand
people usually could get to a hospital
once they get infected this is almost
100 this is this is almost two
magnitudes higher uh that we were
measuring at the beginning however
talking about this risk is more
complicated it has multiple levels uh
needs multiple levels of thinking but
this was the real uh if if I had to pick
between these two and while fatality is
terrible and it's absolutely dramatic
how many people died of covid but at the
same time what really caused the
collapse of Health Care Systems was the
high hospitalization rate because
hospitals got filled and capacities got
filled within days and weeks
um and those people don't they they
didn't they didn't all die of course and
luckily all of them survived but the
hospital system collapsed while
hospitals were getting filled up with
patients so
importantly thinking about which aspect
of the disease we're we're focusing on
like that really really defines the
course of of our pandemic uh pandemic
reaction on the population as a reaction
to the pandemic focusing on the fatality
which did not seem too high at that
point in my personal opinion was
probably off Target and probably it took
us in a on a route where a lot of people
did not really feel the true um the true
power of this risk
now once we defined what risk we're
talking about and where our focus is
there's the human component of what we
can do and this toolbox really forces to
think about think about when we
communicate about risk how can we think
beyond the scientific understanding
beyond that percentage number and try to
think about who we are talking to
and this is what does not what doesn't
come naturally to scientists and I can
speak from my my own experience it
certainly does not come
um naturally to me to uh to communicate
risk to a wide range of uh of
populations who who who are not in my
same research field
um
but we have to understand that there are
certain components that if we want our
messaging to be effective and if we want
the patients to uh and people to take
action uh on a certain risk we need to
take into consideration one knowing our
audience
sounds like a cliche and for those who
who have ever worked in the field of
marketing I guess not many of you like
this this is something that we hear
every day knowing our audience because
it's very important
um there's no one General Public
and
um when we communicate to the general
public if I hear that nowadays I cringe
because we can't do that there's not one
population we're talking to there's
actually a lot of segments and a lot of
different groups uh um disadvantage more
advantaged lower socioeconomic status
higher socioeconomic status and there's
all sorts of uh people who we need to
tailor our messaging to because their
level of scientific understanding and
also the things that they care about and
the channels through which we can talk
to them will be completely different if
we want to elicit a good behavioral
change and an effective behavioral
action on that risk we need to think
about how we tailor our messages to
certain populations
um and this really uh goes hand in hand
with building trust with the communities
that we're talking to and you might say
that as a scientist how can I do that
and do I like this is really my role
it's not only our role above we can do a
lot think about building communities on
Twitter on scientific platforms on on
social media nowadays scientists are in
a different position if you want to
build community if you want to build
trust with the community there's ways to
do that it's not it's not easy and it's
not straightforward and it's not in the
books but but there is a way there's a
way to do that because
um gaining trust during an emergency is
way harder we've seen that in the mental
models people actually lose trust during
a state of emergency so if there's not a
huge in basis of trust
um we're in not in a great position
the second Point here which might come
as a surprise to scientists
um don't shy away from emotions in your
delivery of risk
do talk about the emotions emotions
actually don't take away from the story
they act to it they empower the story uh
and they make it more powerful
um if people see that on the other end
of um of the communication there's a
human being the story will resonate
better than if they see that that
there's there's a robot-like person
who's spitting out data at a very very
high speed
setting expectations is in the middle
what's known what's uh what's known what
uh you know who does what when what what
do what do people need to do what's
coming up uh what are the next steps in
terms of treating the risk that we just
identified when will additional
information be provided super important
setting expectations is is absolutely
important when talking about risk
and a little bit tied to that
acknowledging uncertainty and what we in
what we don't know there will be a lot
of things when we need to get out there
and communicate whether indirectly or
directly with with the audience
uh that we will not know and that's
normal and that's part of that's always
part of the package uh and acknowledging
that uncertainty rather than saying that
this is the complete truth right now
actually builds trust actually builds uh
builds a better story and there's a
better story that people resonate with
it's acknowledging uncertainty is a plus
it's not a minus actually I think
there's Flawless misconception around
that in terms of Storytelling it
certainly certainly helps
and then stating commitment right
explaining what public actions are being
taken and and why I have what is our
commitment to the wrong how are we
trying to solve the problem right now in
the background so these are just a
couple of elements that we really need
to think about as we're communicating
the risk that we just found out about
and then the last piece of this toolbox
is how do we fight misinformation and
can we do that as scientists or as
individuals
and isn't it isn't it the task that is
beyond us well certainly it's a huge
task and certainly attacks it as being
very intensively researched and I don't
think we have the golden
um solution and the gold standard for
how to deal with misinformation and how
to attack it from different angles but
there's a couple of things that that are
key considerations that we need to think
about and we can't think about once it
is of the essence
if there's a situation when there's
something coming out there's an
emergency coming up uh we need to be the
first out there with messaging that is
as correct as possible and as
science-based and as based on the fact
as much as possible because it exists in
misinformation research this concept of
um of information vacuum and
misinformation Pockets if there's a lack
of information about a topic and the
public goes online and starts searching
for them there's no information that
lack of information for sure will uh
will suck in some sort of information
that is not correct that Gap wants to be
filled and that Gap will be filled um in
the 21st century with um uh with uh with
all the uh with all this information
that is just proliferating online so we
need to we need to find those gaps the
uranium we need to fill it with great
with good information and accurate
information easier said than done right
now once um you know once thinking about
okay the misinformation is actually you
know spreading and it's and it's and you
can argue it's spreading actually as a
pandemic or as a disease there's an
infectious disease then there are at
least two approaches that we can uh do
there one we can take the approach of
post-exposure once the misinformation is
out there we can debunk it right and
then the other thing is that before the
misinformation gets up but we have a
really good guess of what that
information could the misinformation
could look like if we can predict that
but we can we can do something that's
called the inoculation so let's just
Spam the minute on on these approaches
first of all the treatment post exposure
uh to misinformation which is debunking
how do we do that there's a very
important sequence to debunking
misinformation we can't just go out
there and say this is not correct this
is a lie and I know better because I
have the data it doesn't work we can't
do that but it doesn't work
what works is this sandwich approach
where we start with the facts we start
with what is known with what is
scientifically correct to our best
current understanding then we talk about
the myth out there the misinformation
out there and what is the audience
exposed to what's that misinformation
and we only talk about it once it's key
because if we keep repeating uh the same
misinformation that are that actually
our audience is in a more beers towards
that messaging and there's a risk that
we're just hammering in the same
messaging a little bit more than uh than
our own scientifically correct messaging
so talking about the myth just once
reiterating the misinformation once and
the next step immediately is debunking
that and showing where the logical
fallacies are and showing what is
incorrect in that misinformation and how
that misinformation was built on on
wrong facts or it was constructed based
on health uh well measured facts about
constructed in a in a wrong way and then
we close with the fact again you
reiterate the fact we reiterate the
correct information so this package
seems to be effective and there are
studies with public health messaging
which show that these they show promise
uh these uh like this mix of approaches
the last piece here is preventing the
misinformation which is much more in a
much more theoretical State uh it's much
more uh it's much more theoretical to
think about but vaccination is a good
analogy actually funnily enough for
thinking about preventing the
misinformation spread because what we're
really trying to create here is some
sort of cognitive immunity for the
audience so when the actual
misinformation hits they're prepared and
they say no no I heard about this I I I
I know what they're trying to do here
so how does this work well there's the
vaccine part uh which is really a
forewarning of the name misinformation a
forecasted hey misinformation is coming
uh someone's gonna say this and we
predict that they're going to say this
and that and it's going to be incorrect
don't listen to them that it's a fall
fallacy and um and and here are the
facts instead so once that is done then
there's a process of psychological
inoculation which is hypothesized
according to this Theory which is where
uh where the the person generates a
cognitive cognitive antibodies of course
these cognitive antibodies don't exist
but it's very it's a very good uh
analogy so then later on they're immune
to that misinformation and when the
actual misinformation hits there will be
more more perceptive to that uh to to to
sensing the logical fallacies and and
the problems with that misinformation so
that is something again and more
theoretical but it's it's being tested
in the world of Public Health and chose
great promise so there are a couple of
things that we can do and I hope I hope
you can see that we're not totally lost
and also this is not a complete picture
there's much more uh that that we can
talk about that I really wanted to give
you a high level kind of uh peek into
into box of risk communication and and I
hope you found it interesting and uh
let's keep talking if you have questions
or if you want to reach out please do I
really thank you for your attention and
let's keep in touch